musha
lost a leg
when she was two years old
from landmine
i thought that i should do something for
her
dr terchai chirikat is working with the
world's first elephant hospital located
in thailand
since it opened more than 4 000 injured
and sick elephants have been treated
i'm the first one who invented the
artificial leg for the elephant
using his knowledge as an orthopedic
surgeon dr tur chai designed moosh's
artificial limb when she was just a baby
accounting for the elephant's weight and
size
as she has grown pressure on the
prosthetic has increased causing it to
break
so a new one is created every few years
this is a challenge for me too every
time we fix it we
improve it
it's more
sturdy
stronger
this you know
in the textbook
sometimes try and early
when she obeys me give her candy
and she know where the candy is
she uses a trunk to go into the pocket
he knew
i did operation
on her foot about 15 years ago
but
she remembered me
she liked to come closer to me
she showed a sign of
salute or happy
i think it means
so much for her
she can
live a normal life as she should be
you